[Music]
i have heard a rumor that you at one
point were on tinder so i'm gonna be a
nosy reporter right now
are you single i i'm single at the
moment are you back on tinder
my pr told me to say no but yes i am on
today we like the tea we want the truth
here i've got to deliver the tea to
canada
the best tinder dates i've had have been
with people who have no idea who i am
yeah that's perfect when we go to a
restaurant and one of my songs comes on
that's when it's difficult because then
i'm like in my head i'm like please
don't put two and two together like like
just ignore the song i talk louder
[Music]
if you ever change your mind i
understand that that song really did
come from a painful breakup for you yeah
question number one does he know that
was about them yes
question number two how did he react
we'd gone through this this situation
and it didn't really end
well uh and i was kind of left with this
almost like this tether and i was saying
in songwriting sessions that it just
feels like every now and again he would
text me he'd be like i miss you and it
would yank up my heart
so i sent him it um as a demo and he
sent me a selfie back of him in tears
far away
made your move better off keeping my
distance he's heard it he found it
difficult to listen to i can't imagine
that it was nice for him that it was a
single man